we are raging upwards in terms of the
emissions on the planet
and we've got to turn that around
increasingly i see ceos of major
companies around the world
beginning to move spontaneously to
commit their companies to net zero to
decide on whether if they're an
investment firm or bank
how much they can lend or what they can
invest in
climate related emissions reduction
activities
so i think there's a huge new market
opening up i think it's very exciting
and in my judgment it's going to be the
biggest market we've seen in the world
since the industrial revolution do you
have to drive that like your work with
other countries in setting admissions
goals
how does that tie into the private
sector type trends
that you're talking about well the
private sector will ultimately obviously
make its own decisions but what we're
trying to do is galvanize
groups of entities to come together
in order to uh challenge other companies
and other corporations
why are we doing that because there's no
way any government
will find or has the trillions of
dollars necessary to affect this
transition
and when you add up the other
entities that are coming to the table we
have the potential
of huge amounts of capital going into
alternative renewable
fuels possibly hydrogen exploration get
green hydrogen
you have the possibilities of storage of
one kind or another which could change
the entire game
just as people have for years in venture
capital bet on some particular
technology or
disruption in the marketplace that's
going to happen now in the energy sector
because people feel compelled
to try to address this challenge and
governments are going to create
incentives for some of that capital to
move in certain directions for instance
president biden is planning to build 500
000 charging stations in america
which will certainly begin to make it
more possible for people to feel good
about buying electric and transitioning
there will be a transition in the auto
industry gm has announced they're going
to only produce electric vehicles by
2035.
ford is moving in a similar direction
mercedes volkswagen
car companies around the world are
setting dates for when they will no
longer be making an internal combustion
engine
a lot of that is driven by market forces
your job is to negotiate with the other
countries of the world
presumably on emissions right reduction
targets see that affects the market
force
that becomes the part of the transition
in the market if all of a sudden i mean
what happened in paris
196 countries came together they all
decided
they were each going to pursue their own
plan but they were all going to reduce
emissions
that meant that they had to find the
means of doing so and in the first year
after paris and second year after paris
uh several hundreds of billions of
dollars went into alternative renewable
investment
that's the direction we were moving
until president trump
stopped the momentum by pulling out of
the agreement and he gave license to
some reluctant countries to sort of pull
back
but we will regain that now you
mentioned president trump and his
withdrawal on a lot of environmental
regulations all the rollbacks but a lot
of the private sector trends that we're
talking about continued on anyway that
investment
grew exponentially coal-fired power
plants closed
things like this happened all around the
world but not enough in enough places
so then what is success for you do you
think that figuring out new numbers for
every country more ambitious
numbers will lead to this do you need to
see the private sector investment
already follow how do you define
success well success will be the vast
majority of nations
coming to the table in glasgow and
putting down
plans for how they're going to target
net zero by 2050
and what they're going to do in 2020 to
2030
to be down paying on that goal uh if we
can get the as i say the vast majority
of nations taking that seriously
uh that is success and and many
scientists
have said the ipcc which is the u.n
scientific arm that does the analysis
has said to us
two years ago we have about 12 years in
front of us within which to make
the critical decisions necessary to
reduce the worst damage
from the climate crisis so that's it
we've used up two of those years
not enough happened we now have about 10
years or so
within which to get the job done